ASNGRCR  MINUTES IN
THE TEXAS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
LLILOMK THE FBI EAN AGENCYE SHR
>>> THER NM
TEXASUNE THAT HASRTED TO SHED
, ING TH
TRIBUN UVALDHO
PO R D
VIDEO,IMS
THIS -- HEAVY D OFFICERSD CONFRN
ORN
HOUR DESPITE SVI THEEND N TWELE.
MEANING THEY WERE ALIVE.
INSTEAD THE DOCUMENTS Y
WAITENT
LOWER LENT FIR ENTERED OL
ATGAN SHOOTING A CLASSROOM AT LD
POLICE DEP
RICL
RECAZING ROTHOOTER.
OFFICERS HAD GHE
HAD AD
HAND.
BUAT THERE WAS MORE E COPS STIIK
UVALDE ETAN INTERSTREW THBY PHO
ATTORNEY GEORGE DONDO GREW UP IH
OTINGSHE TOLD THE TRIB SEVERAL
MPSE WITHOHIS POLICE AND CAMPUSI
HT THE RADIOS ULD BEL IMPEDIMEN
OULDN'T WORK INSIDE DING.
M DOORD  DN'T KNOW O91LLFR IE A.
D INTRUDERS  SESS HE WAS  A  TH
BREAKING WINDOROASSROOMS AND ECM
WH FEAO MUCH NOISE THGUNMAN'S N.
ARRADONDO TOLD THEBU
QUOTE, NOT SGLE RESPONDING
WENDF THE STUDENTS FROTHE CLASSF
NTS AND TEACHERS
ACCESTO
SHOOAND ELATED THE
T TO
RVIEWSTH TIME.TORNDPTHE SCHOOL
TH
WERE TAKECALLY TORE SUCH HAD UD
THEY ADDED MORCERS.
ANTETES IN THE LAS
SUCHREHEMETHN
N ARERETIRING IN 2017 AHETINGS
N L  SHEBUREAU'S ACTIVE SHOOTERR
MUS MY FIRSTN,ANHEAT B? SOM IS
DON'T?
>> WELL, I T WR OW
PORAIN PICFITHEY HAVE THNFO DO F
IEWED FOR THIS
PIECE THATONTAINED THE
INRVHIEF H NOW
HEY WOUL. EQUIPMEEQUIPMENT.
YOVEYOU.
ONCE T  TTHE RE T
TEL
YOU SAID -- YOUR R
QUOTOMSAYING WE DI.
THIS.
WE DIDHIS.HIS.
THERE WASN'T A WE Y. DOESN'TNOT.
SO IN ONE HANDS E AS POLICE
HOOL DISIC
AND EYICERY
, THEYID THEM VERY-
MOUNT OF TIME.
WITH THEMULD HAVE HAD HIS UN.DR
>>OWN THATELSEVE TAKENROL?
>> YEAAT'S -YOKNOW IIENCED POLI.
EORCER THERE WA T
BU GROUP THINK
OPON IE,OMHAS TO BE IN.
AND AIE SHOULD  CHARGE
DIRECTED
SOMEBODYO BE IN CHARGE YOUULHAD.
F SMRICT.
F THS S IS THEY HAVE JUS
ITUR AND SIX PTI SCHOOLS.OW,POLU
AN, MAYBE THAT'S
MET TO
TH
>> OKAY.
NG TO
GENERALLPPF LA
ME.
ASSESS THE SITUATION
NOW BECOME A B
SITUAT
NOW HEARRE'VE GOT TO? THE CHRONA
.
ERE'S -- WT  SAY
THERE'S NOE.
MY PEOPLE WHO DID THAT
THE COP'S
GIVE US AN AFTER-ACTIO VES US M.
BUT WE HAVE A LOT ELLS URE SHOTN
RES ORS.F OTFID OF HEEOYOU HATH
I MECT THAT THEYOUBREAK CLASSRO
WOULD BE ASKING MY
>> OKAY.
YOUR BOOK IS CALLED "STOP THE
CAN WE STOOOTING
ARE THERINYPE OU
THEY SD EFORE
TO TH?OOK  CALLED
"STOP TH BUT, YES. OAGS THAT WE
FORYOU O E IS KIND OF VE MOVE
ON ARAJECTORY TOS CE.
THEY GET ITHEN THEY PLAN AND
WES,, EIL THE  TINFORMATIO PEOPL
KNOWHA 9E SOMEBODY ELSE IS TOLD
S INTEE FO. DY.
>>OUSTEN TO Y --
LE AROUND YOU.AH, 80 TO  T
R YOUNGETER U OW, THE AVERAGE A
AS
>> YES I
ESCAPE MEANINGUN IF YOU HIDE IMR
DISRUPTEES UNARMED.BE NG A WEAPT
FIGHT ANT THIS GUY.
YOU CAN.
BUT FIRS